okay [ __ ] and we're [ __ ] back it's
your boy cycle double um what to say
here my eyes are getting real dry like
I'm at eyedrops like so I'm gonna
blanket like a little [ __ ] for a while
just make sure I don't [ __ ] dry out
and I you still got a moisturize me or
so often because I sit in the chair for
so long okay we're we got that crazy
girl at a glassed that's is uh hell yeah
[ __ ] ass oh you're no [ __ ] okay what
else do I need objectives get the arming
key should I have to get that [ __ ]
yeah great my man that's what I got to
do but I need to return this to eat way
and I also got a top dangler right I got
all this stuff let up [ __ ] be crazy
let me hell up fat boy
yes I'm half on a harness oh yes free
bad how's the song [ __ ]
okay yes I wonder if I could [ __ ]
make it to lobby now last time I was
talking in there Ian
a Beretta am i right um yeah got that
yes okay now I got to figure out where
the [ __ ] to get out of here
mm I don't know where the [ __ ] I am
I'm going to be doing a lot of running
this season
oh great great yeah back at batch holy
[ __ ] that made me jump
[Music]
where the [ __ ] is they ah sounds like
that okay
I'm just going to [ __ ] it around it
Flutie right where I got everyone real
quick yeah I'm in this one [ __ ]
yes
I'm trying to get to the [ __ ] lobby
neck's away to lobby yeah yeah yeah
Nikolai's louder yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay okay
okay now where am I
oh this is a very good spot to be in oh
[ __ ] no it's not
[ __ ] there's nowhere to [ __ ] your
statics for the elevator all right this
is going to [ __ ] suck this is going
to suck a lot of dick
in quick chef or passive we're passing
them all yet
[Music]
just [ __ ] is that okay we got a good
plan
[Music]
okay security human race ourselves now
that I get out I guess that's where I
gotta go okay remember oh yeah okay hey
badge Morgan dr. you good to see a
friendly face - her mouth was worried I
might not make it here myself but my
luck held out ah I hope you don't mind
but I made use of your fabricate had the
right materials to make several refill
canisters will glue Garnett again also
if I may show you with this kit I think
I can increase the fluid intake
efficiency without detriment to the
weapons affected me okay yeah Morgan I
was worried Arlo his rescue team had
intercepted you Nancy and nine black box
operators not a rescue team rescue is
not among the list of commands hey man
not now
yes of course but does his arrival may
help us as long as you have not killed
him hanger you see doll he's a recipient
of several neural mods are standard
array of combat tactics interrogation
mods as I'm sure you know your father
the board is very thorough doctor anyway
please present your conclusion to Morgan
EJ is there is a point uh well yes you
see does mother early see series betas
and vulnerable
such he has old-school thinking on some
matters we removed them you may forget
his mission here is trying to [ __ ]
Tahlequah
you've been trapped in the simulation
situations normally the tests are only a
few days long Anders calmly thank you
the strange feeling I hold lightness
gift to the world my hands he will live
on I wish my wife could have heard him
play again that was brave oh you [ __ ]
bet
ah no yes Alex is correct it could work
and preserve what we have learned here
we have to try noggin Kleenex there's so
much to lose destroying the station that
should be the final option what did I
[ __ ] connect I can fail something not
the first one dr. egg way this is the
only course of action with a significant
probability of success Janice you
designed me to assist you I have more
instructions but I can't access them
until you've recovered both arming keys
no [ __ ] way
ego if there is a point ah well yes you
see does mother early see series betas
and vulnerable as such he has old-school
thinking on some matter we remove them
he may forget his mission here yet we
would still have access to the shuttle
and the way home provided his pilot
acknowledged remains intact it's a risk
but worth taking I think he'll have to
be subdued of course my friend at Task
Force to you there is no one else alive
on the station who can pilot the shuttle
it's worth the try and there's been
enough killing
what thank you the strange feeling I
hold lightness give to the world my
hands he will live on thanks my wife
could have heard him play again again I
wish I had was brave of you to recover
the connectomes for me I appreciate it I
appreciate me of you
trans they have done for me I've always
felt that consciousness is
like music than computation okay how do
I talk to this better that's not a
security station is a lot more than what
hope you don't mind I was using your
work area nice setup
who'd have loved to have one of these in
engineering I took the liberty of
restocking your supplies found some food
on the way up left it on the desk
don't worry they're alien too
I checked it no teaching in existence
you are lecturing me on my part of Lexus
but for sure you are going to fire me to
bed you're sweet on me I could tell I
can't I do this it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
Morgan what
how does a want from me mmm-mmm-mmm
I'm saying about Kineo a [ __ ] in some
ways I wonder if doll is worse little
Tyson what's in here he's BC joke
your office is relatively secure come
back if you need to rest or use the
fabricator relatively secure he says oh
thank God we're to Luther class okay
[ __ ]
and
okay we're going to go for this down
okay
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy let's say here
okay I'm just going to take this
[ __ ] okay you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I'm going to go [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
look work
why that's okay
where are they
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] egg in that [ __ ] heal
me run heared anymore [ __ ] can you hear
me
the discoveries made of or tell us one
seemed to validate some form of pants
psychism consciousness there's a
fundamental force that exists everywhere
one degree or another it seems plausible
then said an organism evolve which they
were able to look I hear it
you
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] okay so I still have it Luther
glass thing where is that
don't you pipe loads of source got [ __ ]
and
the [ __ ] is in here let's see here
so decryption key
the [ __ ] [ __ ] some far-off okay here we
go here we go holy [ __ ]
[Music]
I don't care is that [ __ ] the system
taking out attack at iPod you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I guess is eat [ __ ] mmm any other
countries
we hack this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a lot of
hacking to do so it's a [ __ ] copycat
why the copycat
[ __ ] run please contact a qualified
[ __ ]
and one if I could just [ __ ] set it
up over here now be so dope
attention station leadership has issued
an alert all personnel should report to
muster stations immediately and await
further instructions holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
out what the [ __ ] I'm having to get out
of this place this may be like a really
bad idea
please don't open that door please don't
open that door
out [ __ ]
I know I [ __ ] heard them I know it did
okay so what am i doing in here
tiny cabinet camera cabinet and in here
there's nothing in here why the [ __ ] am
I in here oh that kills of things and
arity
there's really nothing in here okay [ __ ]
it anything else you like now up there
oh I kill Tyson phone box that's why
yes sorry took [ __ ] out I can't put that
in there this guy in here where's the
turn
yeah [ __ ] bet your [ __ ] med area
recycler [ __ ] okay I guess I'm just
going to use this account with my back
shuttle bay
so you in there let me just go around
real quick and get that now great
hmm okay
maybe lot of hacking today now I'm very
surprised by this okay okay hey hey
hopefully we will tell me how is he
thinking thinking donate thinking I'm
lagging and being a guy getting on Jane
Jenga
yeah but just let's cut the [ __ ] I'm
talking about I think it does gonna be
like one try again yeah give me like one
oh [ __ ]
and I set those up there nothing
this is a live feed now don't show any
[ __ ] Tyson
okay here we go [ __ ]
great okay I mean I think but no ammo
how the [ __ ] twice on him no wave [ __ ] I
should have made that ammo I think they
did how the [ __ ]
oh thank god wow I just got insanely
lucky you want for me get oh [ __ ] what's
that what's that over there
I don't lapidary Allah and - cn9 lockbox
operator ready to deploy please stand
clear of aperture
move this Holloway
[ __ ] sighs you get that last leverage
high 15
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] I don't even know where
to [ __ ] go Soph excellent office
anyone in here
[ __ ] a night what happened to this dude
yes
waiting room shuttle boarding employee
entrance [ __ ] go this way
I'll check each one is a hack that helps
anyhow just takes forever though so
annoying ow
thank God
what is that
I laugh okay
[ __ ]
okay okay I mean I love pilot a pilot
[ __ ] this man I'm just [ __ ] eating
that little sin I hear any computer so I
can [ __ ] download the area map okay
stay here
superkick now okay where is the suit
repair kit that's spare parts there we
go
okay boys will eat this [ __ ] a chest
oh now why not eat this [ __ ] yeah
I see the [ __ ] can I call Bob yeah I
can
oh [ __ ] good idea okay doing good that
way stairs where what the [ __ ] is that
way okay work out we're going [ __ ] a
there all over place
firing angle ooh yeah me
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] ah ah ah
so what else I have one of these
can they attack turns they have to let
me set up resuming [ __ ] head
ah
a lot of [ __ ] hacking on this game oh
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] why you like this one come
[ __ ] I am
I'm a hacker
where's the anime
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
leaf isn't like a cute hack ah
I guess now they're [ __ ] festive
[ __ ] little [ __ ] huh ow [ __ ]
can I block that I bet I can I bet I
[ __ ] can watch this look the big suit
you want the make it stop now
now now please stand clear about you
wait [ __ ] I got a quick load it's
getting pretty bad here
I gotta hack their traffic a silenced
pistol [ __ ] I like two of the three
spare parts
great the [ __ ] up there hex s1 thank
you very much thank you very much and
I'll hug this I'll thank you very much
thank you sir
[Music]
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
and how about that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
thought you're so smart operator
deployment resuming okay I got to put
this one right in front of their
obstruction detective please their
amateur of the brief obstruction
detective please clear aperture of the
beat obstruction detective please clear
amateur of the brief
pick up [ __ ]
okay
drink this I [ __ ] it all apart my
neck again I need to fortify this place
okay did I four to five this year now
[Music]
okay we got this place secure okay
nowadays a panic anyone donates a panic
clean [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] okay I have to keep moving here hi
yes I am the employee
[ __ ]
okay okay get out it download area map
that's what I [ __ ] ate hey jet okay I
guess it's fine those guys [ __ ]
really dropped and ranked that
twelve lower level okay so right here
nothing
every deployment redeeming [ __ ] a one
more
a cat-cat and clear
[ __ ] that one's all [ __ ] up totally
upset
okay I guess we'll keep on guys [ __ ]
I'll have any health get [ __ ] love hot
in the [ __ ] bathroom
hey it's [ __ ] water if that I think
here why the [ __ ] is this here so weird
have like rooms where there's nothing in
there
something happened here and it's fresh
our don't know what hand it
the [ __ ] is this
that's weird
IQ can I guess okay this point I [ __ ] it
just drag out anything
[ __ ] okay yeah like I'm doing really
well
operator deployments resuming okay so
let's see where I gotta go hmm level
three and yeah there's a little bit of
it okay get up there I guess I have to
grab look
question new operator
and - cn9 black box operator ready to
deploy please stand clear - sure there's
gotta be there's probably just like one
down there
not very dispenser there it is
it's like spearing yeah that's it
this is a white cap another one looks
great on there [ __ ] I'm blocking that
[ __ ] off okay
okay so let me just [ __ ] finish off
these [ __ ]
I'm sorry a picture tomorrow weapon
guess I thought lie that I don't know
that yeah okay takes a little water
don't want to be parks well shut where'd
it go
okay I don't know what's going on there
[ __ ] it that noise yeah [ __ ] yeah the
noise okay I got the grass shotgun
wait okay time to get the [ __ ] out of
here
so now that like gets rid of it so
useful Jesus the [ __ ]
just like I like that
super Becca where is it parts nope why
don't I see it others better keep pick
up pistols it's over here
my cat okay
great holes on the ceiling now locker
room I check that out
I was going away
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] this is one it's not
graded 51 all back who's that guy
okay okay let me go back smart shower
quick now calm down
[ __ ] I can make everything now about my
life I tell
can't make a sugar batter so I might as
well just [ __ ] go all the way with
this
okay write down really good way down
like one smug one and I get the net
return oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
I really [ __ ] myself up huh
okay how do I get it this is the door
got Parker okay
take that
Hey
scanning target no typing the jury out
the [ __ ] is gross now what the whole box
where is this [ __ ] I get [ __ ] up here
alright well it's been an hour a little
Canada here I gotta grab this thank you
guys